j'étais en discuter
la jeunesse cette belle jeunesse et puis
demandé ce que j'avais fait de ma vie
que je réfléchissais tout compte fait
est ce que c'est parce que mon père
était menuisier que j'ai eu une vie en
dents de scie est-ce que ça explique le
fait que toute ma vie je suis passé du
possible à l'impossible est impossible
au possible
j'en sais rien toujours est-il que comme
viens de vous le dire
christian je suis né dans un petit
village qui s'appelle roissy en france
il ya de cela très longtemps que c'était
aux derniers millénaires c'était il ya
70 ans
mais dans une famille où nous étions six
frères et soeurs parmi lesquels trois
handicapés profond une période mise y
est j'ai jamais eu de vélo jamais partis
en colonie de vacances alors aux pages
rico êtes si vous restez pas bien fini
sauf que moi ça m'a donné du ressort
beaucoup de choses était impossible
alors pendant que les copains faisait du
vélo bobinette pendant qu'ils allaient
en colonie de vacances le petit michel
il n'a jamais été bien grand même encore
maintenant ils allaient s'asseoir dans
l'herbe et regardait les avions se poser
au bourget il disait un jour je serai
dedans pas de vélo donc je vais aller
dans les avions
je vais est assis devant c'est à dire je
vais conduire des avions et comme ceux
ci me paraissait très modeste
je me disais je vais tout simplement
faire une chose s'est créé ma propre
compagnie et probablement par esprit de
revanche sociale
déjà à l'âge de 8 10 ans je disais je
veux mettre mon nom sur mes avions
c'est fou c'est dingue c'est impossible
à faire sauf que j'en avais rêvé
alors je les fais et pourquoi parce que
je me disais voici la vie dont tu rêves
et tu va tout faire pour la rendre
possible
alors j'ai passé mon adolescence à me
cultiver mermoz saint-exupéry
j'ai également beaucoup potasser mon
livre de géographie que je le trouvais
beau mon livre de géographie
il y avait les châteaux de la loire
il y avait la tour eiffel il y avait le
mont blanc le mont saint michel et tout
ça je sais pas si vous vous en souvenez
eh bien c'était toujours photographié du
dessus je trouvais ça magique et je me
disais pas que je vais partir en
colonies alors un jour tu ferais un truc
c'est que tu partiras acté avions temps
viendra des passagers qui feront qui
volera gratuitement parce qu'ils vont
payer ta place et a donc superbe way
superbe
sauf que j'ai pas de pognon alors j'ai
emprunté 20 mille francs parce que
c'était l'ancienne époque on parlait en
francs j'ai emprunté 20 mille francs à
des copains de travail
et puis je dis je vais poursuivre mon
projet mais entre temps il faut quand
même que je fasse un passage que je m'
établissent dans la vie et donc
l'adolescent se meurt à mener tout
simplement à passer le concours de
l'armée de l'air la petite porte
petite porte et on découvre la première
visite médicale je suis possesseur d'une
bio qui alors l'envi d'être pilote et
puis il monte sa compagnie on va pas
faire de gestes déplacés
mais on sent que ça s'éloigne le support
dans le fond si on peut pas être pilote
on sera mécano on sentira de kérosène
quand même et on sait jamais ce qui peut
arriver eh bien je fais l'école de
sainte écoles de rochefort s'il en a
parmi vous qui connaissent et me voici
muté dans une belle région
la bourgogne devenu bourgogne franche
comté en clair je me retrouve sur la
base aérienne de dijon qu'on appelle
l'académie de la chasse sur un avion
extraordinaire le mirage iii qui doit
toujours être derrière si je fais pas
erreur et dès l'âge de 20 ans puisque
nous avions vendu 8 400 mirage à 22 pays
dès l'âge de 20 ans eh bien je me
retrouve instructeur sur un truc très
bizarre le réacteur du mirage parfait
génial super premier étage j'acquiers
donc une expérience dans ce domaine
et puis vint en 22 ans
on établit sa petite vie personnelle on
rencontre une gente dame
et puis on fait un premier enfant et ce
premier enfant
il se trouve que il un comportement
bizarre et on découvre qu'il est autiste
profond l'a 47 ans aujourd'hui il ne m'a
jamais dit papa il me dira jamais papa
ça refroidit mais heureusement il ya le
rêve qu'elle a on va continuer trois
autres enfants au passage lors d'une
famille de quatre enfants
un handicap et un salaire ne peut pas y
en avoir deux
donc passer des brevets de pilote si
vous voulez pour ensuite repartir dans
son rêve c'est très compliqué alors cela
va 3h30 du matin à 4 heures on part avec
de musette
on prend des piles de prospectus est
journaux et on va distribuer sa dans les
boîtes aux lettres de dijon et avec le
puck ça rapporte et dans l'est quand
même content d'aller passer son petit
brevet de pilote à l'aéro club de
nuits-saint-georges puisque je sais ça
enfin devenu un pilote qui va être
capable de conduire un avion eh bien je
suis donc surpris j'ai repris ma
trajectoire et de ce fait et bien je
crée ma compagnie qui portera quel nom
le mien torigni aviation chez permis
alors me la partie avec les deux pilotes
avec lui 20 mille francs 9 la partie
shell aérospatiale parce que il faut que
j'aie des avions mais j'ai pas les
moyens de les acheter dans les moyens de
les payer
alors je représente mon projet me dis
c'est pas idiot on va vous en prêter
sauf que il va falloir payer de location
quoi c'est pas c'est pas mal comme sujet
j'arrive sur les aides sur les aéroports
pour tout simplement emmené mes
passagers sur ses belles régions que je
viens de vous citer petit problème je
suis accueillie par des gens
avec des grandes dents qui sont les aéro
club et qui partent du principe que je
viens de cliquer le pain de la bouche
moi je suis professionnel sont
associative c'est pas grave
donc ça va pas bien finir ça va pas bien
finir
je vais déposer le bilan je vais rendre
les avions je vais rentrer chez moi
j'aurais pu de femmes j'aurais plus de
gosses c'est parce qu'ils sont devenus
et aujourd'hui je suis incapable de vous
dire combien j'ai de petits enfants
c'est comme ça ça fait rien ce qui ne
tue pas rend fort disait nietzsche alors
je me retrouve sans domicile fixe sdf
rabat mais sdf et l'aviation s'est
terminée le rêve c'est fini mais c'est
pas grave dans le fonds gelés réaliser
puisque j'ai bien sûr voler nos belles
régions avec des avions qui portait mon
nom
ces programmes j'ai trente deux ans la
vie est belle elle s'ouvre je redécouvre
l'amour je conduis des bus de ramassage
scolaire parce qu'il faut bien manger
parce que les huissiers sont là tu
penses y en a dans la salle ne l'est pas
ça dépend bail expire enfin bref je
retrouve du boulot dans la formation
une société qui s'appelait rejlek
spécialisée dans dossier formation en
entreprise dans le cadre de
l'automatisme là où betty etc terrain ça
se passe plutôt bien je le 158e dans la
hiérarchie et un jour le patron
m'appelle le patron m'appelle et me dit
monsieur tories voilà j'ai décidé de
créer un nouveau poste de directeur
commercial
parce que l'ancien il est pas bon
d'abord et puis le poste est mal définie
ensuite
donc c'est vous que je veux je comprends
pas ce qui m'arrive che numéro trois
dans l'entreprise du 158e étage je vais
les centres afin je monte au troisième
plus exactement fabre est et je suis
plutôt content je dis moi l'aviation
c'est derrière mais ça y est je suis
chef c'est pas mal là bas
sauf que ça c'était au mois d'avril 2000
1987 3 septembre 1987 périphérique à
paris il ya un camion koblitz arrêté un
camion koblitz arrêté qui pousse 28
voitures devant lui et la première
voiture c'est pas le pot c'est la mienne
elle vous en avez là des photos quatre
heures intenses portable je ne sais plus
qui je suis parce que je sais pas ce qui
m'est arrivé
les chirurgiens me demanderont aussi je
suis croyant je vois pas pourquoi mais
il m'explique ils me disent parce que
nous on comprend pas pourquoi
en définitive vous êtes là vivent alors
aujourd'hui m'écouter par tradition
familiale chez de confession catholique
alors ils m'ont dit vous irez à lourdes
alors comme l'année d'après je savais
pas trop où aller si vous voulez je suis
allé à lourdes et jean mis quatre heures
am des inscrits quatre heures à
désincarcérer de la base ils sont forts
nos amis pompiers
on leur doit beaucoup de choses la vie
en tout cas dans mon cas et puis les
séquelles laissées qu'elle sait que
normalement je n'ai pas le droit de
rester plus d'un quart d'heure deux
bouts de wirth et brady ce quinté je
veux pas tourner la tête à gauche ce qui
fait que je m'arrange pour mes baskets à
droite pour parler à mes amis j'ai fait
une mutation génétique tellement le choc
a été violent et je me fais quatre
piqûres par jour et accessoirement j'ai
été soigné ne rigolez pas c'est triste
cinq ans au médiator voilà mais j'en
suis sorti c'est bien voir et je vous
jure que c'est vrai et puis un jour que
tu es un peu comme celui d'aujourd'hui
j'étais en forme et je croisais les gens
leur faisait sourire d'un seul coup je
fais un sourire à qui a un mec que je
connaissais qui avait été pilote sur
mirage iii avec qui j'avais travaillé
dans le passé qui est contents de me
revoir et moi je suis très heureux de le
croiser et me dit tu sais j'ai quitté
l'armée j'investis dans des avions et si
tu veux je peux pas te les miens
alors je pensais pas du tout que j'y
reviendrai alors il m'a dit va pas
compliquer ce que tu faisais tu leur
fais mais avec des avions puis voilà et
puis tu me paiera à l'heure de vol au
lieu de louer forfaitairement etc
enfin bref c'est reparti c'est reparti
et c'est ainsi que l'on nous à l'ombre
survolé le grand saint michel ont var
survenues ce qui est derrière vous avez
reconnu
ça va super bien tout tout tout va bien
on va créer école de pilotage avion
hélicoptère
je vais avoir jusqu'à 20 guide au musée
de l'air du bourget
l'un des plus grands dr au nautic au
monde je suis celui qui fait les plus
gros chèque tout va bien nul n'est
prophète en son pays mais figurez-vous
que là où j'ai appris à marcher
entre temps ils ont fait un aéroport
qu'ils ont appelé charles de gaulle est
là se trouve que j'ai d'exclusivité
depuis 25 ans des visites de l'aéroport
charles de gaulle l'envoyer comme quoi
les planètes peuvent s'aligner
j'ai fait de l'événementiel des choses
dans le genre veulent en patrouille
acrobatique aussi vous avez normalement
la patrouille breitling numéro un
mondial numéro un mondial le leader
jacques bothelin on faisait nos mêmes
rêves ensemble dans le même avion il ya
40 ans et me disais je rêve de créer ma
patrouille et moi je lui disais je rêve
que ce que vous savez déjà
et bienvenue comme moi nous sommes allés
au bout de leur rêve et je pense même
qu'on les a bien dépassé alors
simplement pour vous laisser quelques
frissons va pas vous les mettre en vol
le temps ne manque
sachez simplement convoler à 650 à
l'heure avec des gens comme vous ils
n'étaient pas habitués à le faire qui
rêvait de voler sur un avion de chasse
et on veut la 650 à l'heure à trois
mètres les uns des autres pour ça qu'on
est habitué à boire que de l'eau
voyez ce qui vous empêche pas après de
le payer un verre tout cas je le saurai
l'apprécier alors tout va bien parce qu
on sait bien construit en plus j'ai
refait ma vie personnelle juste
ambitieux et enfin je suis tombé je suis
pas tombé
voilà salut salut brigitte elle à 200 km
d'ici mais je n'embrasse elle me refaire
cinquième enfant la vie la vie a repris
et un jour je rencontre
peut-être que je vais rencontrer des
gens du même acabit ce soir je rencontre
des gens d'air france qui me font
expliquer ce que je fais ils me disent
écoutez ça fait 20 ans que l'on cherche
et trouve quelqu'un qui puisse s'occuper
d'un nos avions parce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui veulent qu'ils rêvent de voler
dessus qui n'ont rien à faire à new york
etc ont surtout pas les moyens d'y aller
et j'en redemande lequel ils me disent
concorde
donc là faut pas que je sorte du cercle
rouge mais je vous jure que je suis
tombé quand il m'a expliqué sa il c'est
pas vrai c'est pas possible eh bien ils
m'ont demandé donc de faire force de mes
idées et nous avons donc créé un
programme unique au monde
un programme unique au monde composé de
trois parties une première alors tout ça
c'est avec la cravate c'était avec a été
gentil avec les gens et le matin leur
faisait visiter l'aviation d'hier au
musée de l'air j'avais vingt guides
là-bas 28 conférencier en début d'après
midi
on a visité ce serait plus possible
aujourd'hui pour des raisons vous savez
aussi on a visité aussi fini monsieur
probable continuer quand même
hu et donc on faisait en deuxième partie
une première partie d'après midi
l'aviation d'aujourd'hui en allant
directement sur les pistes de roissy et
à bien son dealer aviation de journée il
restait plus qu'une chose c'était du
sang ou frais dont concorde pour
réaliser quoi un vol qui nous faisait
partir de roissy qui allait sur
l'atlantique comme c'est écrit derrière
et à un moment donné
rentré dans l'autre sens pour s'opposer
ou à roissy et vous avez devant vous le
type cap ont souvent dû organiser
réaliser les voeux les plus chers pour
les nuls par
et en les faisant le plus vite possible
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
eh oui
et louis formidable cette histoire j'ai
vendu du rêve encore d'où le voyez là
quelques uns sans quelques secondes une
petite minute en veulent on faisait
roissy le avons deux minutes
[Musique]
on avait sur l'atlantique en faisant km
toutes les secondes et demie si ça vous
dit rien c'est la vitesse d'une balle de
fusil à la sortie du canon j'avoue voix
sans passagers à bord dans la balle de
fusée en vol l'avion s'allongeait
d'environ 25 cm
je sais messieurs ça nous en modeste
mais imaginez un peu j'aurais peut-être
produit la mère josée beaudoin mois plus
tard superbe
je vais même en réaliser le dernier vol
de 31 mai 2003 des milliers de passagers
j'ai emmené sauf qu'il ya eu un crash
dadis us à 25 juillet 2000 on va pas
trop parler de ça simplement dire que si
tout on avait fait son boulot se serait
jamais arrivé et que ceux qui sont morts
ne sont pas coupables des défaillances
mais on fait quoi on repart ouest ce
jour là je perds 80 par son activité
je revois passer mes copains disent
vicié je revois passé le rsi je vois pas
ces soucis je voudrais passer cela et je
dis comment on va s'en sortir et en
france me dit écoute michel nous on va
pas communiquer sur concorde mais toi tu
vas être le seul à les affaires
commercialement encore des actions ça
nous permettra de voir si encore des
gens qui volent redécollé dessus donc je
cerne depuis d'autres testeurs
voilà des intentions des bonnes
intentions de du public et on leur
mettra en vol c'est pas le pot
d'ailleurs on le remet en veulent aussi
tôt après les attentats de new york
c'est compliqué et on va l'arrêter
dix-huit mois après pourquoi parce que y
est il ya la guerre en irak
à tort ou à raison chacun jugera enfin
juge le président chirac décide que les
fronts se liront pas en irak
de ce fait les américains qui étaient
ceux qui utilisaient de plus l'avion est
bien le fond comme on dit communément la
gueule
ce qui fait qu à pain parfois il ya
moins de passagers dans concorde que
deux membres d'équipage est dur à gérer
la maintenance pour une multitude de
raisons va prendre 72 % en douze mois
72%
ouais invivable donc la décision est
prise d'arrêtés l'avion donc on arrête
ou encore on fait le dernier vol en dans
l'histoire alors on repère très
important d'activités machin les meubles
qui touchent pas s'apprendre je te tue
ma femme est partie faire des courses je
dis moi je vais le cinglé j'en ai
ras-le-bol de ce pays
voilà et puis me dit tu sais je suis
toujours là et puis qu'est-ce que je
vais faire court tu seras plus là quand
oui quand il sera plus là donc on
redémarre dans la vie dans sa peau était
simple parce qu'il a fallu lutter contre
les uns contre les autres il a fallu se
reconstruire j'avais faire de grève de
la faim dans une banque au et récit
parce que j'adore les sas terminera le
15 mars 2015 par une évacuation
d'urgence pas en hélicoptère en voiture
vers l'hôpital de dijon pour un début
d'année c'est alors je vous rassure je
vais très bien j'espère vous entendez
que nous en rendez compte
je vais très bien la vie continue et
aujourd'hui ce que je veux c'est
transmettre tout ça et dans les échecs
dans mes réussites dans l'ombre dans la
lumière
j'incline seule certitude c'est que dans
la vie pour vous pour moi tout est
possible rien n'est impossible